[Music]
do you feel like Comic Con has so many
uptight rules written by whoopsies that
it makes your brain hurt Jamaican me
crazy just like that t-shirt y'all get
the F out of there bro huh and head on
over to just as good as San Diego to
LaVista and don't be such a puss
everything is allowed fake pens ninja
swords shoe knives even though Google
glasses
what about selfie sticks yo they're
mandatory bro
and will there be hot girls all the time
but there's also all sorts of awesome
stuff to do at douche con like by
example you and your boys could pose for
photos with one of the suits worn by
Dwayne the rock Johnson on that TV show
violence then test your pomp impact with
our chestbounce rental meter plus may
helpful seminars like gene embroidery
welding a super nice chain wallet
shooting editing and distributing your
own revenge porn how to do that thing
while you're up in the club and you act
like the champagne bottle is you dick
[Music]
and Android charging stations and
pull-up bars every 50 feet so never lose
your arm which is good because the girls
are definitely on their way Plus lots of
meat and Greece with douche icons like
Bobby Flay Steve endure dumb from
Entourage Bret Michaels pickup artist
mystery one of DJ Steve Aoki's cakes and
Charlie Rose I guess what the girls just
texted me they got a thing to do first
but they're definitely coming you know
it baby
[Music]
duquan 2016 conveniently located in a
party tent at a Home Depot parking lot
and what about the girls they're not
coming
[Applause]
[Applause]
I wanted to say
you